Situado en el Golfo Pérsico, Qatar es un
país de poco más de 10.000km2. Para que
os hagáis una idea, es algo así como la
mitad de El Salvador o 7 veces más pequeño
que Panamá.
Pues bien, cuando en 1971 obtuvo su independencia
del Reino Unido, Qatar era un lugar remoto,
hostil y pobre... muy pobre. De hecho, era
uno de los territorios más pobres de todo
el imperio británico.
Y... no era para menos.
La península de Qatar, un lugar, donde las
temperaturas superan en verano, ojo, los 50º,
y prácticamente todo está cubierto por desierto,
es, sin duda, uno de los lugares menos habitables
de toda la tierra.
O… al menos lo era, porque hoy, amigos,
Qatar es el país más rico de todo el planeta.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Los ciudadanos de este pequeño país disfrutan
de una renta per cápita real de más de 125.000
dólares, casi tres veces más que la de Francia
y 5 veces más que la de Chile, por ejemplo.
El que un día fue un país prácticamente
despoblado, un país que apenas lograba subsistir
con la pesca, es hoy una especie de Caja Fuerte
del Tío Gilito en España o del Tío Rico
en Latinoamérica.
El gobierno de Qatar tiene hoy inversiones
y propiedades por todo el mundo, es la cuna
de Al Jazeera, el medio de comunicación árabe
más importante; y... su capital Doha es todo
un despliegue de rascacielos, centros comerciales
y automóviles de lujo.
(“Una mezcla entre Mónaco y Las Vegas,
pero sin juego ni alcohol. No hay lugar para
la sobriedad, todo es ostentoso, enorme y
brillante en Doha”. Ángel Sastre.
Durante todo este proceso de cambio, Qatar
ha pasado de ser un oscuro refugio para predicadores
fundamentalistas islámicos que,
incluso, en la mismísima Arabia Saudita se
consiberaban radicales, a ser hoy tal vez
el país más abierto de Oriente Medio
Con la excepción de Dubái, aunque por supuesto
este último emirato no es un país.
En la Doha de hoy podemos encontrar universidades
internacionales o, por ejemplo, la conocida
como “Church City”, un complejo con iglesias
protestantes,ortodoxas y católicas, como…
es el caso de la Iglesia de Nuestra Señora
del Rosario.
(“6 mil personas abarrotaron nueva iglesia
en Qatar para su consagración”. ACIPRENSA
Llegados a este punto creo que está clara
la pregunta que podemos hacernos ¿Cómo ha
conseguido Catar semejante transformación?
Veámoslo.
(LA BENDICIÓN DEL GNL (GAS NATURAL LICUADO))
En otros vídeos hemos visto algunas claves
de porqué algunos países son tan ricos.
Pues bien, en el caso de Qatar… digamos
que las claves son mucho más simples y se
resumen en dos elementos: petróleo y sobre
todo, Gas Natual, muchísimo Gas Natural.
Sí, así es.
¿Decepcionado? Pues esperad un momento porque
la historia tiene su miga.
(En década de los 40 se descubrieron los
primeros yacimientos de petróleo qatarí.
Cuando este comenzó a explotarse seriamente
allá por los 60, las cosas en este país,
tan pobre por aquel entonces, comenzaron a
mejorar… pero.... no tanto.)
Lo cierto, amigos, es que no fue hasta inicios
de los 70 cuando la Shell descubrió el gran
tesoro de este país:
“el campo norte”, el mayor yacimiento
de gas natural del mundo.
Claro que por aquel entonces el gas natural
no valía mucho.
Sí, me explico, por aquel entonces el gas
sólo podía ser transportado por gasoductos,
por tuberías, y Qatar estaba demasiado lejos
de cualquier lugar que pudiera consumir este
recurso, así que, bueno… digamos que la
propia Shell se olvidó rápido de este descubrimiento.
Pero las cosas no siempre iban a ser así,
para nada.
En 1995, el antiguo emir, Hamad bin Khalifa
al-Thani, que por cierto abdicó hace relativamente
poco, en 2013, dio un golpe de estado aprovechando
que su padre estaba de viaje en Suiza.
Pues bien, Hamad bin Khalifa al-Thani llegó
al poder con una idea muy clara: el futuro
de Qatar pasaba por el gas, había que explotar
esas inmensas reservas.
Y dicho... y hecho.
El nuevo emir apostó muy fuerte por una tecnología
que por aquel entonces no estaba ni muy desarrollada
ni muy extendida:
la licuefacción, es decir la capacidad de
llevar el gas natural a una forma líquida
para poder transportarlo como si de petróleo
se tratase, en grandes barcos.
Para ello, amigos, hay que enfriar y mantener
el gas a una temperatura de 161º bajo cero.
Pues bien, el Qatar del nuevo emir decidió,
precisamente, invertir enormes cantidades
de recursos en impulsar el desarrollo de esta
tecnología y poder usarla a gran escala.
(Gracias a ello, Qatar está hoy en la vanguardia
y es el mayor exportador mundial de GNL. Gracias
a esta tecnología, Qatar puede explotar,
intensamente, sus reservas de gas, las terceras
mayores de todo el mundo.
De hecho, tres cuartas partes del gas qatarí
fluyeron el pasado año a países asiáticos
como China, India, Corea del Sur o Japón,
su mayor cliente.)
Y no solo eso, los complejos industriales
desarrollados por Qatar trabajan a tal escala,
que el país ha conseguido tener los menores
costes de extracción y licuación.
Por ejemplo, llenar un metanero de gas natural
licuado es 4 veces más económico en Qatar
que en los mismísimos EEUU.
Este, amigos, es el gran secreto de este pequeño
y rico país.
Ahora bien, como sabéis y ejemplos nos sobran,
además de saber extraer los recursos,
para que no nos ocurra lo que a Venezuela o Angola,
hay que saber utilizar el dinero que se genera.
En esta línea además de esta primera apuesta
inversora, la riqueza de Qatar tiene algunas
claves adicionales.
(QATAR POWER)
Desde que Hamad bin Khalifa al-Thani llegó
al poder en 1995 las cosas han cambiado mucho.
En sus 18 años al frente del país, la población
de Qatar se multiplicó por cuatro al tiempo
que se convirtió en el país más rico del
planeta.
Vamos, que al antiguo Emir le sobran motivos
para sacar pecho.
Pero... sigamos. El caso es que Qatar comenzó
a generar muchísimos recursos económicos
y ¿qué pensáis que se ha hace con ellos?
Pues a pesar de las apariencias, fundamentalmente
los han invertido… dentro y fuera del país.
Así es, Qatar ha constituido la "Autoridad
de Inversiones de Qatar", un gran fondo para
invertir dinero por todo el mundo.
Se le conoce como Qatar Power, porque, amigos,
este fondo cuenta con más de 330.000 millones
de dólares.
Ojo porque la población de Catar es de algo
menos de 3 millones de habitantes, pero de
estos apenas unos 300.000 son ciudadanos,
son qataríes, así que echad cuentas de a
cuanto sale cada uno... Sí, a más de un millón.
Pues bien, este gran fondo tiene propiedades
por todo el mundo:
(Por ejemplo en 2016 Qatar fue el cuarto mayor
inversor en oficinas en todo EEUU. Tan solo
en Manhattan ha invertido en los dos últimos
años 5.000 millones de dólares en proyectos
inmobiliarios, incluida la compra de una parte
del Empire State Building.
En Londres, gran parte de la City pertenece
a este país. De hecho en la capital británica
es posible vivir, trabajar, comprar y alojarse
exclusivamente en propiedades de Qatar: oficinas,
apartamentos, hoteles…)
Y también tiene participaciones muy importantes
en muchas multinacionales:
Por citar sólo unos pocos ejemplos, Qatar
es uno de los mayores accionistas de empresas
como Volkswagen, Iberdrola, Barclays Bank,
Tiffany, Shell, o incluso el gigante Rosneft,
la empresa de petróleos del gobierno ruso.
En el siguiente gráfico podéis ver cómo
a medida que la producción de gas y petróleo
se ha incrementado también ha crecido la inversión del país en el extranjero:
Y por supuesto, también dentro del país
se están invirtiendo grandes recursos:
decenas de miles de millones para autopistas,
puertos, aeropuertos, centros de investigación,
centros financieros, etcétera, etcétera.
¿El objetivo?
Que el día de mañana estas inversiones sean
capaces de suplir los ingresos del petróleo
y el gas natural… claro qué hasta que ese
gran negocio se termine... aún queda mucho.
Puede amigos que está vocación por invertir
y no gastar el dinero generado por los recursos
naturales sea una de las grandes diferencias
con otros países también muy ricos
en  recursos naturales
Es fácil gastar pero hay que pensar en el
futuro. ¿no os parece?
(POR LA INDEPENDENCIA EFECTIVA)
Cuando Hamad bin Khalifa al-Thani llegó al
poder, también tenía otra idea clara: Qatar
debía ganar peso internacional.
Veréis, durante años, Qatar fue controlado
de facto por Arabia Saudita y el nuevo emir
no se quitaba de la cabeza la invasión de
Kuwait por parte de Irak.
Si Qatar quería sobrevivir necesitaba ganar
entidad propia, peso internacional. De otra
forma, cualquier conflicto con Ryad podría
acabar con la independencia del país.
Además, el gas natural, ahora sí, podía
pagar las facturas.
Así que, se buscaron alianzas internacionales.
Cuando en 2003 Arabia Saudita “invito”
a Estados Unidos a sacar sus tropas del país,
Qatar no dudo un momento en ofrecerse como
destino... ni en gastarse 1.000 millones de
dólares en construir las bases.
(Hoy más de 10.000 soldados estadounidenses
están en el país, la mayor base de operaciones
de la gran potencia norteamericana en la región.
Podemos decir que Qatar contrato la mejor
póliza de seguros.)
Por otro lado, se puso en marcha Al Jazeera,
con el objetivo de ganar influencia, algo
en lo que tuvieron mucho, mucho éxito, como ya vimos aquí en VisualPolitik.
Y también, desarrollaron una intensa política
exterior para ganar influencia internacional.
Así Qatar no dudo en apoyar las primaveras
árabes o acercarse a Irán, por ejemplo.
Había que ganar apoyo social y político.
(EL BLOQUEO)
Toda esta estrategia política puso furiosos
a sus vecinos de Arabia Saudita y Emiratos
Árabes, que como respuesta anunciaron el
pasado junio de 2017 un salvaje bloqueo contra
Qatar acusandole de apoyar a grupos fundamentalistas
y terroristas.
Increible, Arabia Saudita haciendo semejante
acusación… ver para creer.
Es verdad que Qatar tiene algún agujero negro,
al fin y al cabo es una monarquía absolutista…
pero... es un buen aliado de occidente, especialmente
de Estados Unidos y uno de los países más
aperturistas de la región.
Lo cierto, amigos, es que el boicot tenía
como objetivo terminar con toda esta estrategia
internacional de Qatar y cómo decirlo…
ponerles en su sitio.
Pero… a decir verdad está siendo un gran
fracaso.
(Por un lado a mostrado que la posición de
Ryad no es tan fuerte: muy pocos países se
han sumado. Incluso Kuwait y Omán no lo han
secundado.
Por otro ha impulsado los lazos de Qatar con
Turquía e, incluso, Irán. Y desde luego
Qatar ha demostrado tener músculo para hacer
frente a esta situación.)
Es más, Qatar ha anunciado que acelerará
algunos planes de apertura, por ejemplo para
atraer inversiones extranjeras o para hacer
más fácil obtener la residencia permanente.
Pero... de todo esto hablaremos en otro vídeo.
Eso sí, para terminar, aclaremos una cuestión:
Qatar tiene muchos puntos negros: las condiciones
laborales de muchos trabajadores de países
pobres; la situación de la mujer o la falta
de democracia.
Y, además, el modelo aún tiene que demostrar
que puede funcionar sin el gobierno.
Porque... a diferencia de Dubái, aquí el
protagonismo no lo ha tenido la iniciativa
privada sino la pública.
Entre otras cosas por esto, Dubái sigue por
encima en casi todos los parámetros.
Pero, amigos, no sería justo no reconocer
otros avances y puntos fuertes, como el ahorro
y la inversión productiva... o la apertura.
En fin, turno para tí ¿Quién crees que
ganará el pulso entre los países del golfo?
¿Lo ganará Arabia Saudita o lo ganará Qatar?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo dale a like. Un
saludo y hasta la próxima.